Smith is in you're gonna help here
because he's done taking goodness they
got a concussion try to take that right
there 30 a game in the first water they
get on some pretty good stars Paul
George Johnson defense got help if he
needs it get yourself a basket
quick hands here and Paul gives it up
right now and you can see capela comment
and it's on to the other side Joe Young
[Applause]
I stopped by Paul to stay in it the
links of George's Beverly tried to jump
into Paul George and boy we get a hand
on it percent in his last 15 or 16 games
he decided to be aggressive so he'd get
his shot as the help comes from Paul
George to get that block he decided
agree on three to start
Paul Pierce blocked away by Paul Joel
was read and no challenge for Taurus Bob
Hope
[Applause]
via Paul George comes that ball is still
going up barely getting to the rim does
a great job of getting there and
protecting his teammate as Deng was
trying to get a foul ball Jordan
Sullinger spins in the lane it's knocked
away the great help by Paul George he's
made a difference coming in here's
George Hill the Euro step to the end
that means with your mind with your body
right here
Paul George does a good job not what
active looking to see where the ball is
knows where his man is going and once he
realizes the opportunity to come help
watch he gets his hands on the ball
that's how the patients are able to get
out because of the deflection by Paul
George nobody back to stop George
[Applause]
George died by as many as six but these
are the plays that win games falsely by
four
advantage back cut stolen and they were
expecting that out of that timeout ellis
to heal up and under long enough to back
chopped up yeah turns played just 16
minutes coming in and as Paul George to
come and help out there running is young
how about the boss pass or just sort of
sitting on the rim won't fall the lead
is three that's drew a job this is Paul
George did that and George lays it in
change now for Brooklyn as Sean
Kilpatrick who has been starting is in
and that's stolen by George
I mean quietly what the patients have
done a good job of Chris
pass the Paul George
and 51 points 13 rebounds 13 assists in
their win on the road in Philadelphia is
a great block anticipated right there
here's John Wall look out look out boy
he's the puller going baseline to
baseline not that abounds now how about
Paul George running him down from
half-court watches from behind up rods
to the right Eric come there you go six
of seven but they want the last five to
finish if at number seven see bad pass
it is George your head of the field
puts a gown that Paul George is
struggling only 2 for 9 and really he
has not had that many good looks Kevin
Love got blocked in it now the rebound
deflected and stolen by George he leads
the NBA and that's apartment groans a
bad pass but it comes back in and George
Avila finishes behind the three-point
line no George what a play what a play
by George
the state protocol to play block the
file as he was coming down against AZ
Brad with the second half and he said
they're a tough team defensively guys
for the Thunder gonna have to keep at it
locked inside the thunders fifth block
shot along the City
and on the basketball past Jones is
going to attack George who's been
recovering luck his second shot of the
ball game
for George Westbrook is back
tough shot in the weeds goes to the deck
no call Sefolosha in transition Oh Paul
George punishing Sefolosha is attempt
never got close to the glass of the rim
the night of sensational blocks as pg13
says check this out
he timed it perfectly to swap that thing
out of out of the air and out of bounds
Mitchell gave it back to him who could
believe he had to fall his hands over
the top favors
blocked by George gets it back shot
clock deep George went to stay of my
goodness in possession starting up kicks
it out to geralyn's by mistake without
Jones on the move
[Applause]
block that shot it's on a bounce though
Vince appiah III honestly feel that
Jones had no idea that George was
running him down okay
maybe because he was concerned about the
guy that was in front of them back with
the ball my goodness this call was it's
it's a good thing still here for George
looking over the top let's go faster
Stepan clock city scores if you don't
get your act together let's peel tail
line - intercepted by George number one
in steals the other way
they're starting with two rookies
Collins Anderson in the starting lineup
shrewder off the lazy pass denied by
Paul George the [ __ ] with odd men in
transition the erosion oh boy no fouls
to give either way 45 seconds to go
inside George to flex the ball now to go
work or through the one - nobody was
playing well last couple game freak shot
outside since Westbrook is short
Mitchell racing by George and then
Gobert folks by Adams short shot clock
thunder doesn't get anything out of that
but then grant gets back to challenge
and how about joy rocking Mitchell if
the Rams took a pop on the back of the
head see slow to get up
trot back down nice play Paul George
there's Westbrook
now sugar
take it away Jackson can he turn the car
by George who painted on the backboard
Locke terrific timing by Paul George and
then he kept in at play
picks up the loose change on the floor
gets it out to shooter delete son Willie
cauley-stein up from behind how about
Paul George catch it up to the plate
causing the jump ball on the block is
the defense at Paul George plays I mean
this is a sewer to for Willie
cauley-stein and he catches him right on
top of the ball right at the top
something with that Blake how did tear
his Ferguson know to step out like that
is that the players edges appeal for the
game
speaking of feel for the basketball
another block and Adams in transition
throws it down up ahead Mitchell runs
riding the pole that called it up
vertically and had a great defensive
play now finds grin grant some space
lays it up and in
is the best on that sequence and he's
still in attack mode
I love that because you know you can
shoot the three gotta set Luka dr.
Duncan Watts out here we go
Josh eight wins coming back to double
digits down he's a good start Paul
George's fourth steal grant sidestep
Spellman oh what a finish
[Music]
[Applause]
but what a denial on the defensive end
by Paul George you talk about access
denied at the rim ball George just
perfect timing to not you define your
opportunities where I can't get that
with me to fall I'm interested to see
this matchup because
but personally sometimes 2-shot you
don't take that's the best decision
my apology
that's why that number is so big they
usually get 48 in their atomic roots not
walk by Paul George shot clock winding
down George came in from behind and
swiped it away from Leonard numbers
again grant in transition these scores
Oakland lag from downtown how about that
Paul George got the steal and the finish
while we talk about Vantage of you know
the smaller size Dwight Powell
Adams activities now Palin underneath
inside George came over to help Adam
blocks the shot the glass was feeling
out there you look at Steven Adams
numbers over the last three games twenty
and ten being more aggressive than this
this team he gives steel
the author's really quick begin with the
ball developing he has eight points for
the Lakers here especially the last
eight points as he turns the ball over
yeah Paul George is waiting for that
steal drawing kick what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content what's up you guys
this Taylor Brooks with bleacher report
make sure that you subscribe for some
more video content